[Musica]
se qui davanti a noi ci fossero in fila
tutte le stelle del cielo
vedremo che alcune brillano ed altre
sono spente
perché io voglio svelarvi il segreto del
risultato straordinario e alcune ma ora
mettiamo un attimo da parte le stelle
concentriamoci su di voi pensate a
un'attività un progetto un'impresa che
voi non avete fatto per paura di non
ottenere risultati
oppure pensate un'attività un'impresa
una vostra idea che state realizzando ma
vi spaventa un po pensare a quello che
otterrete non so ci può essere qualcuno
ad esempio che ha pensato di iniziare un
percorso universitario ma non lo fa per
paura di non riuscire
io voglio darvi la chiave su come fare
ad ottenere risultati competitivi dai
vostri progetti
guardate io non sono un astrofisica non
studio i cieli non studio neanche gli
astri
io ho un dottorato in economia mi occupo
di scoprire come gli imprenditori
possono ottenere risultati dalle loro
aziende e un'azienda è un progetto molto
complesso soprattutto quando in azienda
c'è una famiglia ed è proprio studiando
le realtà familiari che io ho scoperto
qual è la
chiave per ottenere risultati
competitivi
ora quando noi intraprendiamo un
progetto pensiamo sempre a due cose la
prima è il cosa pensiamo a tale attività
fare cosa fare di solito quando
intervisto i capi delle imprese
loro mi dicono guarda noi vogliamo
aumentare la profittabilità della nostra
azienda
e allora investiamo in innovazione come
se l'innovazione mettere i soldi in un
libro innovazione fosse una garanzia di
successo
eppure io ho visto tante aziende in cui
questo non è sempre vero la cosa che si
fa non è pensare al cosa mai pensare al
come voglio dire
viviamo in un epoca in cui tutti ci
dicono come fare le cose
siamo pieni di manuali come vestirci
come truccarci come ottenere risultati e
cerchiamo continuamente queste
informazioni per date io conosco delle
aziende in cui il leader pensa è proprio
questo che cambiando il suo stile posso
ottenere risultati ci sono dei leader
che adottano uno stile molto autoritario
loro dettano legge ma per i padri
padroni e poi che renda le imprese
veramente competitive non è dettando
regole su tutto e le volte noi perdiamo
di vista qualcosa
guardate se davanti ci fosse un
bersaglio e io lo dovessi colpire io
fisso il mio obiettivo ma la mia mano è
estremamente importante
guardate cosa succede se esposto la mia
mano io faccio più fatica a colpire quel
bersaglio importante
è il da dove verso dove
da noi siamo sempre concentrati sul
verso dove
sull'obiettivo ci dimentichiamo che c'è
anche un da dove india il dove la chiave
di svolta non solo il cosa il come il
cosa il come vengono dopo il dove dopo
la direzione che voi date alle cose ma
guardate il dove non è importante solo
per gli oggetti è importante anche per
le persone
ora immaginatevi che io sia una
ballerina stupenda che stessi facendo
una performance di balletto non lo so
alla scala
insomma morte del cigno e se lo facessi
qui al centro trasmette rai a tutti
qualcosa un'energia non lo so
arriverebbe la pelle d'oca vi verrebbe
almeno da piangere
ma se la stessa performance sono sempre
io stesso cose lo stesso come mi
mettessi là dietro
poi non arriverebbe un bel niente
il mio risultato non ci sarebbe il dove
non è solo un senso di luogo fisico
anche un senso mentale quello noi
assumiamo un punto di vista
poi vediamo le cose da dove verso un
dove ed è il nostro punto di vista
mentale che poi determina le nostre
azioni i nostri comportamenti e le
nostre scelte e quindi ci garantisce un
risultato guardare da dentro le cose non
è come guardarle da fuori ma è solo ed
esclusivamente se le guardiamo da dentro
che possiamo fare qualcosa possiamo
cambiare le cose
sapete come ci sono arrivata
all'importanza del dove facendo una
ricerca
io ho selezionato degli hotel
delle imprese familiari praticamente
tutti uguali a vederli da fuori tutti
nella stessa zona
tutti e appunto aziende familiari in cui
si erano verificati almeno un paio di
passaggi generazionali tutti con la
stessa struttura organizzativa lottare
il ristorante le piscine l'asp ai
massaggi fanghi tutti uguali
eppure quando sono andata a scaricare i
dati di bilancio
ho analizzato questi dati e ho trovato
una grande differenza in termini di
performance
c'era chi finanziariamente aveva delle
prospettive economico finanziarie e
molto buone e chi andava un po meno bene
economicamente parlando allora mi sono
chiesto il perché ho iniziato a
raccogliere dei dati
ho raccolto dati sul cosa e sul come
insomma sulle classiche cose innovazione
radicale incrementare gestione delle
risorse umane strategia
insomma tutto quello che noi penseremo
che garantisce un profitto mi sono
accorta che nessuna di queste spiegava
la performance e allora intervistato gli
imprenditori e le loro famiglie e mi
sono inventata nuovo metodo di ricerca
ha proposto loro dei disegni ho chiesto
in quali disegni loro identificavano la
loro azienda
i disegni più gettonati sono stati due e
hanno detto il mio hotel è un
macchinario è il mio hotel è un albero
un organismo vivente
dopo aver fatto questo ha chiesto loro
il dove dove si posizionavano
all'interno di quell'immagine e tali
mettendo insieme i dati di bilancio con
le loro interpretazioni del dove si
ponevano ha scoperto la chiave che gli
imprenditori delle imprese che andavano
meno bene si ponevano come elemento
accessorio rispetto all'immagine
loro erano il giardiniere che portava i
rami dell'albero oppure erano il
meccanico che versa l'olio sulla
macchina gli imprenditori delle imprese
che performavano meglio che andavano
meglio che avevano veramente il
risultato erano quelli che si ponevano
come elemento fondamentale dell'immagine
loro erano il tronco che dava energia i
rami e alle foglie o loro erano quella
rotella principale che faceva girare
tutti gli altri ingranaggi con l'energia
e la loro che davano valore
all'organizzazione stessa e ci sono
altri due risultati secondo me
interessanti che ho ottenuto nel momento
in cui c'erano due imprenditori alla
leadership che occupavano il ruolo di
capo era necessario necessario che
entrambi stessero insieme al centro
dell'immagine
perché se uno si poneva come elemento
accessorio toglie energia e non ci sono
i risultati
e poi se anche vero che qualcuno deve
rimanere al centro per produrre il
risultato anche vero che io ho scoperto
che c'è qualcun altro che deve lasciare
spazio affinché questo avvenga
e allora se anche voi volete ottenere
qualcosa dei vostri progetti
potete fare una cosa semplicissima
ponetevi mentalmente al centro come il
fulcro del vostro progetto
questo garantirà un risultato
guardate vi ricordate che vi parlavo
delle stelle sapete qual è il segreto
delle stelle più brillanti sta nel
nucleo grazie